well we just have so much news after the
long holiday weekend and we have to
start with arguably the biggest news in
the world Tulsi gabbard has left the
Democratic Party
and she's done it with a pretty
conspiracy and lie Laden video now this
is actually not very big news I'm sort
of kind of kidding around its
tongue-in-cheek uh Tulsi gabbard is an
individual who used to be a
congresswoman representing the state of
Hawaii and she ran for president and got
you know like one kind of like a one one
two percent support
um and then she although it was obvious
to some of us that she was clearly a
sort of populist rhetoric reactionary
contrarian of no real substance adding
no real value to the conversation
um not everybody understood that even
some of my fellow leftists kind of fell
for it and she's been more and more
outwardly moving to the right speaking
at CPAC the extreme right-wing
convention
um being selected to fill in his host
for Fox News propaganda Tucker Carlson
and listen this is the final step in her
public transformation it's really not
that much of a transformation so here is
the video 80 seconds in which tool C
announces her principled and defiant
abandonment of the Republican Party
listen closely because there's a lot of
uh a lot of nonsense in here I can no
longer remain in today's Democratic
party that's under the complete control
of an elitist cabal of War mongers now
elitist cabal
that is very carefully chosen language
to appeal to the reactionary
conservative Maga big lie JFK Jr is
currently the vice president type of
people elitist cabal is Q Anon language
do not think that the choice of that
language is an accident now I'm not
saying tool C is necessarily A Q Anon
person I'm not saying that but that's
language that is
finely tuned and tested to press the
buttons in the brains of very particular
people it's not an accident okay and by
the way warmongers remember Hillary was
going to get us into five Wars Biden was
going to get us into five Wars none of
it has happened okay none of it has
happened but they love to say these are
just these are Maga right-wing
conspiracy talking points who were
driven by cowardly wokeness who div
remember the wokeness what they think of
as wokeness is the tiniest sliver of the
left it's not me it's not really my
audience it's not the Democratic party
it's a yeah it's same old stuff guide us
by racializing every issue okay the
criticism that the left racializes
everything is a way to disqualify
a priori any discussion of racism or
racial inequality that that you you go
they racialize everything hard right
move she's gone fully in and stoking
anti-white racism and that's the other
side
the left is
anti-white and racist against whites
the left is mostly white guys that's
that's the reality who actively work to
undermine our god-given freedoms that
are enshrined in our constitution who
are hostile to people of faith and
spirituality and again it's not
hostility to people of Faith or
spirituality it's hostility to imposing
that Faith or spirituality on civil
government it's about openly as Marjorie
Taylor Greene and Beau bear and all of
them have said saying we are Christian
nationalists and that should be
enshrined in civil law that's wrong
that's not constitutional
who demonized the police but protect
criminals at the expense of law-abiding
Americans and remember the number of
people saying defund the police
it's almost zero and the movement has no
power reform absolutely the 10 to 12
point plan I outlined of course but this
is again their new talking point but
remember when they didn't like what
happened on January 6 they went after
the Capitol Police when they didn't like
what happened with Donald Trump at
Mar-A-Lago they go after the FBI they're
not the pro police pro-law enforcement
people they even claim to be
who believe in open borders who
weaponize the National Security State to
go after their political opponent that's
a trump line
this is a full Maga person now
and above all who are dragging us ever
closer to nuclear war
isn't the guy threatening the nuclear
war Putin the one who's actually doing
that now I believe in a government
that's of the People by the people and
for the people oh unfortunately today's
Democratic party does not instead it
stands for a government that is of by
and for the powerful Elite
now I'm calling on my fellow Common
Sense independent-minded Democrats to
join me in leaving the Democratic Party
All right so then she says leave the
party with me so she uses all the
buzzwords that will make the right love
her even more she really hasn't been a
Democrat for as long as I can remember
she's essentially a reactionary who puts
her finger to the wind and says you know
I didn't get any real attention from the
left other than the small cult of
personality I managed to kind of
coalesce around me because I don't
really bring anything to the table so
let's go to the place where you don't
need to bring anything substantive to
the table I can just use buzzwords and
talking points and talk about an elitist
cabal and get attention that's the
conspiracy right that's the Maga right
Hillary was right again guys she is once
again doing the bidding
of the Russians again not a Russian
asset not a Russian agent this is the
type of democracy destabilizing language
that the Russians and the Chinese and
everybody loves now again you can say
well but listen
good for them then doesn't mean fine I'm
just saying the idea that she is
fundamentally acting in the best
interest of the United States as she
claims is obviously not true she's
becoming a great tool of these
authoritarian uh uh right-wing regimes
that love to frame the United States as
being unstable democratically and quite
frankly we are to some degree but it's
thanks to people like this not that
they're pointing out they're causing
that oh Trump really won all this
different stuff so here come the book
deals here come the speaking engagements
if you follow the the sort of money
Trail it leads to the same type of
people they monetize being anti-woke
they monetize
um all the stuff that Tulsi is talking
about here the saddest thing about the
entire Tulsi episode and it is very sad
is the number of fellow leftists who
were Bamboozled by Tulsi I'm glad I
never fell for it go back to my clip in
January of 2019. watch the video I do
about her watch it and you will see how
obvious it was to me at the time what
she was up to sadly many of my
colleagues fell for it but
you can redeem yourself now it's
becoming very clear even to many of them
and I've gotten so many emails from
people in the audience saying David I
totally fell for it you were right I
fell for it I think this is the final
Loop we can close the envelope and mail
it in when you're busy during the day
and you need a quick snack sometimes
you're just in the mood for something
sweet that's when I reach for monk pack
our sponsor monk pack offers gooey
granola bars that melt in your mouth as
well as nut and Seed bars that are
perfectly crunchy sweet and salty but
the best part is that each bar is
plant-based with only one gram of sugar
two to three net carbs and only about
150 calories it's great if you're doing
keto or low carb or like me you just
want to minimize your sugar intake I
can't get enough of dark chocolate cocoa
I'm just a chocolate guy it's great but
they come in other flavors too like sea
salt dark chocolate caramel sea salt
they just launched peanut butter cocoa
chip and dark chocolate cocoa if you
don't love monk pack as much as our
entire team does monk pack will give you
your money back go try monk pack keto
granola bars and nut and Seed bars go to
monkpak.com and use the code Pacman for
twenty percent off the link is down
below